-I want to talk about what's
going on in politics right now
You know, we see
the current president is using
a lot of the levers of power
that are available to him
in taking steps,
hopefully in something
as big as infrastructure.
He's getting checks in the
American people's pocket.
We obviously have a great
many people in this countr
in elected office
who speak ill of big government.
Would you make the case,
based on the time
we're living in right now,
that sometimes big governmen
is a helpful tool?
-Sometimes it's helpful.
It's always gonna be helpful
if it's properly directed.
But in a time like this,
it's essential.
Look, don't forget, I gave you
the first balanced budget
in three decades,
and we did three in a row,
and I left a fourth,
and we paid $600 billion dow
on the national debt,
which was real money back then
This is not that kind of time.
We had a crash in 2008,
which blew a $3 trillion hol
in the economy.
Then we have the coronavirus
crash, which was bigger.
For all of the stimulus mone
that's been spent,
we're still about
3 million jobs short
of where we were
before this thing started.
When there is negative growt
and zero interest rates,
only the government
can provide the impetus
to jump-start the economy.
And since we're doing it,
the President has a plan
to try to shape the future
with modernized infrastructure
including broadband
for all these small towns
in rural areas.
And a lot of transfer
to clean energy.
But things that
are generating jobs.
And a big plan
to help small businesses.
And if we hadn't done that
God only knows how many
million people would have been
thrown out of their apartments
Too many lost their jobs
as it was.
So, yeah, I think they --
You know, people need to jus
park this cussin' the government
for a while,
and let's get the thing
back to ground zero
and start growing again.
Then we can argue about how much
the government should do.
-And it does seem to be
the discussion du jour
in American politics is,
what would you do
about the filibuster
if it was up to you?
-Well...
the filibuster was set up
to ensure prolonged debate
It was used
in the Civil Rights era
to try to kill
civil rights bills.
And starting
in about 1993, or '4,
it started to be used
all the time.
And it was used
on President Obama.
So it's now been used to try
to prevent a repeat of 202
when we had the enormous
voter participation.
So all the states that are
in the hands of people
who don't like that
and want to maintain
a racial income differential
are trying to make it
harder to vote.
I would -- I understand
the President's reluctant
to get rid of it altogether,
and I sympathize
with Joe Manchin,
who's trying to, you know,
stand up for the right thing
and represent people
that voted more than 2-1
for President Trump,
but I think, when it comes
to preserving democracy,
you know, I would suspend
the filibuster,
because I think it's essential
I don't think that we should
be in the business
of going backwards in trying
to drive down voting rights.
I think we need to expand it
And I think that every tim
we've done it before,
it's made us a better country,
made us a stronger country
And it'll do both parties good
to have to get out and compete
for all these new voters.
So, yes, if it were me,
for this one purpose,
I would not allow an expansion
and basically the protection
of voting rights.
These guys are trying to take us
back decades in voting access,
the people that
Senator McConnell represents
-James, you've had in your books
the president's gone missing
the president's daughter's
gone missing.
I sense a theme.
You know, if there's gonna b
a trilogy of books from
you guys, what do you think?
-People really like animals,
so, you know.
[ Laughter ]
-It does feel like...
-Puppies. Puppies.
-Puppies. The president.
Maybe it's a whole litter.
The president's dog has a
litter, and they all go missing.
-Yeah, yeah, you never know.
-The president's family
wants him to go missing.
[ Laughter ]
Will he do that?
-We're in talks.
We're in talks.
-You're in talks.
When do you know --
Last question -- when do
you know the book is done?
Like, when you guys
are working on it,
is it your job to say,
as the expert, like,
"This is it.
We've got it. Send it off"
-Once again,
it's just never come up,
but the other thing
that the President does is
he really insists
that the characters are as dee
as we can make them,
as complex, rounded characters
And that's probably the last
thing that we do, in terms of,
"All right,
this villain is a cliché
rather than a real human being."
And that's probably
the last thing we do.
And at a certain point,
I just go, "I give up.
It's over.
It's done. It's done."
And then there it is --
"The President's Daughter.
-Well, congratulations.
-Thanks.
-I do think both of you --
not just one of you --
both of you are going places
[ Laughter ]
"The President's Daughter"
is out now.